We aren't going to get into the nitty
gritty of fuzzy matching here.
But so you understand how fuzzy
matching works, it looks at words and
calculate a closeness of match score,
based on the similarity of these words.
You could find some basic
information about two of the most
popular algorithms used in fuzzy
matching in the notes below the video.
When we fuzzy match two
data sets together,
the best practice is to use
a sort of waterfall approach
where we go from most accurate matches
down to least accurate matches.
The first thing we want to do
is actually join the two data
sets to identify the records that
do match perfectly together.
And then remove those
records from the mix so
that we can start fuzzy matching
the rest of the records.
We need to select fields that we believe
will identify the records uniquely,
like using their first name,
last name and address fields.
With the exact match records
removed from the whole data set,
we then need to decide on the different
set of fields we want to fuzzy match on.
For example,
if we're working with customers,
we may have their first name, last name,
address, city, state, zip, phone number.
And even their email.
Using different combinations
of these fields,
we can build out fuzzy
matching approaches.
For instance, we might want to
start with just first name,
last name, address and zip code.
For the remaining records that did not
match, we might want to try first name,
last name and phone number.
For the remaining records
that didn't match again,
maybe we'll try just last name and
address.
Each time we're trying
to find some duplicates,
code them with the methodology
used to match them, and
then remove them from the set until we
have exhausted all matching methods.
The remaining records most be
considered to be non-duplicates.